pourquoi le sérumen dans les oreilles
bonne question en fait ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est qu'à la base le sérumen on
l'avait au coin de la bouche mais comme
ça faisait vraiment moche on a fini par
nous le cacher dans les oreilles non en
fait le cumen c'est un peu l'agent de
sescu de nos oreilles le vigile si vous
voulez déjà quand il y a des trucs qu'on
a pas du tout envie de voir à
l'intérieur de nos oreilles qui arrivent
à rentrer quand même genre des
poussières des moucherons et cetera et
ben le cumain il arrive et il les
attrape avec ses petits bras gluant et
si c'est des microbes c'est exactement
la même chose sauf qu'en plus il
contient des trucs qui arrivent à les
tuer et puis dernier truc dans notre
conduit auditif on a des petites peaux
mortes qui se détachent et ben là c'est
pareil le sérumain il attrape tout ça et
ça finit par ressortir à l'extérieur
grâce au mouvement de nos mâchoires donc
le sérumen à l'intérieur il faut pas le
retirer faut juste nettoyer ce qui sort
à l'extérieur ça on en reparlera de ces
jour